est celle-ci :
Si Internet est la nouvelle presse écrite,
qu'est-ce que la démocratie à l'ère d'Internet ?
Quelles institutions voulons-nous bâtir
pour la société du 21ème siècle ?
Pour info, je n'ai pas la réponse.
A mon avis, personne ne l'a.
Mais sincèrement, on ne peut plus se permettre
d'ignorer cette question plus longtemps.
Du coup j'aimerai partager notre experience
et ce que nous avons appris jusqu'ici
et je l'espère apporter une contribution
à cette conversation.
Il y a 2 ans, avec des amis en Argentine,
on s'est demandé comment faire pour que nos représentants,
élus grâce à nos votes
nous représentent.
Marshall McLuhan a dit un jour que la politique
résout les problèmes d'aujourd'hui avec les outils d'hier.
Une question a été notre moteur :
Peut-on essayer de résoudre des problèmes actuels
avec les outils que nous utilisons chaque jour de notre vie ?
Notre première approche a été de concevoir et développer
un logiciel baptisé DemocracyOS.
DemocracyOS est une application web open-source
conçue pour devenir un pont
entre les citoyens et leurs représentants
pour faciliter notre participation au quotidien.
Premièrement, vous êtes toujours informés pour que
chaque nouveau projet de loi proposé à l'assemblée
soit immédiatement traduit et expliqué
dans une langue claire sur cette plateforme.
Mais nous savons qu'un changement de société
n'arrive pas simplement parce qu'on a accès
à plus d'informations,
mais parce qu'on en fait quelque chose.
Un meilleur accès à l'information
doit conduire à un dialogue
sur ce que nous comptons faire ensuite,
et DemocracyOS est fait pour ça.
Parce que nous croyons que la démocratie
ne consiste pas seulement
d'une série de choix, empilés les uns sur les autres,
mais qu'un débat public robuste et sain
devrait être, une fois de plus, l'une de ses valeurs fondamentales.
L'objectif de DemocracyOS, c'est de convaincre et d'être convaincu.
Il s'agit de trouver un consensus
autant que de trouver le canal approprié
pour transmettre notre désaccord.
Et enfin, vous pouvez voter
sur la façon dont vous aimeriez voir votre représentant voter.
Et si vous n'êtes pas à l'aise
pour voter sur certains sujets,
vous pouvez toujours déléguer votre vote
à quelqu'un d'autre, permettant
une dynamique d'émergence pour un leadership social.
C'est devenu bien plus simple
pour nous de comparer ces résultats
avec le vote de votre représentant
à l'assemblée.
Mais c'est aussi devenu évident
que la technologie seule ne suffirait pas.
Ce dont nous avions besoin, c'était
de trouver des personnes capables de se saisir
de tout ce savoir collectif éparpillé dans la société
et l'utiliser pour prendre des décisions meilleures, et surtout plus justes.
Nous avons contacté des partis politiques traditionnels,
et leur avons offert DemocracyOS.
Nous leur avons dit : « Regardez, voici une plateforme que vous pouvez utiliser
pour instaurer un dialogue avec vos électeurs. »
Oui, ce fut un échec.
Un gros échec.
On nous a invités à aller jouer ailleurs, comme des enfants.
Parmi d'autres qualificatifs, on nous a traités de naïfs.
Pour être honnête, je pense que nous l'étions.
Parce que les défis auxquels nous faisons face
ne sont pas technologiques, mais culturels.
Les partis politiques n'ont jamais eu l'intention
de changer la façon dont ils prennent leurs décisions.
C'est devenu assez évident
que si nous voulions aller plus loin avec notre idée,
nous devions le faire par nous-mêmes.
Alors nous avons fait le grand saut,
et l'année dernière, en août, nous avons fondé
notre propre parti politique.
El Partido de la Red,
ou le Parti du Net, dans la ville de Buenos Aires.
Et nous avons fait un saut encore plus grand,
on s'est présentés aux élections en octobre dernier
avec cette idée :
si nous voulons un siège au Congrès
nos candidats, nos representants
voteront toujours en fonction
de ce que les citoyens auront décidé sur DemocracyOS.
Pour chaque projet introduit au Congrès,
nous voterons
en fonction de ce que les citoyens auront décidé sur une plateforme en ligne.
C'était notre façon de pirater le système politique.
Nous avons compris que si nous voulions
faire partie de la discussion,
être assis à la table des négociations,
nous devions devenir parties prenantes,
la seule façon de le devenir est de composer avec les règles du système.
Nous l'avons piraté dans le sens où
nous avons radicalement changé la façon dont un parti politique
prend ses décisions.
Pour la première fois, nous avons pris nos décisions
ensemble avec ceux qui étaient directement
affectés par ces décisions.
C'était un geste très audacieux venant d'un parti de Buenos Aires
vieux de 2 mois.
Mais on a attiré l'attention.
Nous avons obtenu 22 000 voix, ce qui représente 1,2% électeurs,
et nous sommes arrivés au second tour.
Ça n'a pas été suffisant pour gagner un siège
au Congrès, mais ce fut assez
pour que nous faisions partie des discussions,
à tel point que le mois prochain,
le Congrès, en tant qu'institution,
lance pour la première fois dans l'histoire de l'Argentine,
une concertation avec les citoyens avec DemocracyOS
en guise de support, sur 3 articles de loi :
deux sur les transports urbains
et un sur l'usage de l'espace public.
Bien entendu, les députés ne vont pas dire :
« Oui, nous allons voter en fonction
du choix des citoyens. »
Mais ils ont le mérite d'essayer.
Ils essaient d'ouvrir un nouvel espace pour permettre
aux citoyens de s'impliquer, et esperons-le,
ils écouteront peut-être ce qui sera dit.
Il est possible de transformer notre système politique,
sans le pervertir ni le détruire,
mais en le connectant aux outils qu'Internet nous offre aujourd'hui.
Le véritable défi est de trouver, de concevoir,
de créer, de valoriser ces connecteurs
capables d'innover, de transformer
le bruit et le silence en signaux
et finalement emporter nos démocraties
vers le 21ème siècle.
Je ne dis pas que c'est facile.
Mais à partir de notre experience, on tient véritablement une chance
de le faire fonctionner.
Et du fond du coeur, ça vaut
vraiment le coup d'essayer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)